[Musica]
mi sono occupata della direzione della
pinacoteca nazionale di siena dal 1980
al 2017 e ho potuto attraversare in
questo periodo tutta un'amplissima gamma
di variazioni nel significato della
parola museo ed alla maniera di gestire
un museo sono stati anni estremamente
produttivi secondi pieni di entusiasmo
pieni di difficoltà
bisognerà forse fare un momento mente
locale su che cosa vuol dire museo
esempio delle muse cio era il luogo dove
si raccoglievano gli oggetti più
preziosi che fin dalla fin da 20 diciamo
dai tempi più antichi veniva vissuta
come un'esigenza connaturata alla natura
umana circondati degli oggetti di
affezione cioè di quegli oggetti che
scandiscono la tua vita che ti fanno
sentire meglio che ti fanno sentire in
qualche modo anche protetto rispetto
alla necessità di avere intorno a te le
cose con cui stai bene e che su questo
concetto di stare bene vedrete che
torneremo più avanti
museo quindi inteso all'inizio come
ansia di possesso da parte dei
collezionisti
[Musica]
ah scusate ma ormai siamo abituati a
questa mascheratura sacrosanta ma
scusate un
museo quindi corri scusate collezione
come necessità indica proprio nella
natura umana abbiamo trovato delle
collezioni anche in grotte rupestri
antichissime per dimostrare che questa
voglia di circondarsi di oggetti
d'affezione è una specie di necessità
basilare e scorrendo la
l'idea stessa di collezione di museo si
si trova nelle nelle bombe scanner nei
di origine rinascimentale che hanno
questi luoghi dove si raccoglievano
oggetti preziosi e rari che non erano
alla portata di tutti e che non si
trovavano nella quotidianità che
potevano essere naturali oggetti che
venivano reperiti in natura fossili
coralli e pietre particolari e
conchiglie o artificiali a che erano
invece manufatti originati dalla abile
artificiosità umana e quindi questo
diventava una sorta di
orgoglio per il collezionista che poteva
anche distinguersi da un punto di vista
sociale rispetto agli altri non avevano
modo di raccogliere queste queste
meraviglie dalle immagini potete vedere
di questi dipinti quattro
cinquecenteschi come questa mania del
raccoglitore fosse veramente una sorta
di necessità anche delle delle classi
più abbienti per dimostrare il proprio
potere non ci dimentichiamo che i
bottini di guerra sono stati da sempre
un modo per esercitare la propria
capacità di sopraffare un altro il
nemico fin dai tempi dell'impero romano
ma in tempi più recenti pensiamo alle
spoliazioni napoleoniche pensiamo ai
famigerati famigerate i trasferimenti di
interi patrimoni culturali italiani
anche durante la seconda guerra
mondiale e quindi a questa mania del
collezionismo c è come dire ci deve
anche l'accumulo di oggetti importanti e
preziosi e anche la nascita dei primi
musei pensiamo alle gallerie fiorentine
che nascono dalla volontà dei medici di
acquisire quanto più possibile tesori a
glorificazione anche delle proprie
imprese di studioli me dice che
raccoglievano anche la
come dire una specie di summa di tutto
ciò che la capacità umana poteva
realizzare nel latte delle scienze e
delle arti
bisogna però arrivare invece
all'illuminismo al settecento per avere
una nuova concezione di museo il museo
diventa un luogo dove raccogliere i
patrimoni collettivi i patrimoni cioè
che appartengono a una comunità di
riferimento che riconosce in quei
patrimoni una sorta di
trasmissione della propria capacità di
elaborazione culturale
l'immagine del che di quello che chiamo
il mio museo ahimè non più che la
pinacoteca nazionale di siena è proprio
un esempio di quel tipo di atteggiamento
intellettuale nato nella seconda metà
del 700 per da parte per la volontà
della bat e giuseppe ciaccheri che era
direttore
dell'allora
biblioteca del quella che ora è la
biblioteca degli intronati
rispondeva un'esigenza particolare che
era quella di dimostrare che la
grandiosità della pittura senese del
cosiddetta delle origini fondi oro non
l'aveva che migliora quella fiorentina e
quindi lui con una caparbietà ed un
gusto proprio collezionistico di grande
raffinatezza salvò dalla sicura
dispersione interi patrimoni che per il
cambiare dei gusti e delle mode erano
finiti relegati in luoghi molto meno
accessibili e creò questa grandiosa
collezione che oggi è sotto gli occhi di
tutti e che costituisce un vanto non
solo delle musei senesi ma dell'intera
cultura storico artistica per chi voglia
conoscere la realtà della della pittura
gotica usiamo per tutti vi dicevo e ecco
in questa lunga evoluzione io ho
attraversato i problemi legati alla
museografia per oltre trent'anni ed ho
assistito ad una necessità di
aggiornamento di ciò che si deve fare
all'interno del museo particolarmente
sensibile una
la
definizione che fu data nel 1985
dall'international council of museum che
questa organizzazione internazionale che
raduna tutti coloro che si occupano dei
musei è estremamente
valida ancora oggi il museo e
l'istituzione permanente senza scopo di
lucro al servizio della società e del
suo sviluppo aperta al pubblico che
acquisisce compie ricerche espone e
comunica il patrimonio materiale e
immateriale
dell'umanità e del suo ambiente per
finalità di educazione di studio e di
diletto un concentrato di tutto ciò che
è quella che si chiama la mission del
museo che innanzitutto deve raccogliere
i propri patrimoni e conservarli al
meglio per poterli trasmettere ma subito
dopo deve essere capace di trasmettere
ciò che ha raccolto a un pubblico molto
più vasto il pubblico per esempio nato
da questa esigenza di collettivizzare
l'esperienza museale con finalità di
educazione studio di letto ho
sottolineato in rosso questa parola
diretto perché delle varie definizioni
che sono state date nel tempo concrete
quelle elaborate per esempio dal
ministero della cultura di cui ho fatto
parte per quasi 40 anni è una parola
chiave per capire che la chiave per per
capire che la necessità attuale e quella
di esercitare una divulgazione attenta
di cambiare l'approccio nei confronti di
quello che non si chiama più il pubblico
del museo ma i pubblici perché la
visione elitaria di un museo destinato
solo ad essere compreso da chi ha dei
pre requisiti di base che lo portano a
comprenderlo è assolutamente capovolta e
quindi la parola di letto secondo me è
un po la chiave di lettura di tutto ciò
che un museo proiettato verso il futuro
dovrebbe fare noi ci siamo intendono e
coloro museografiche si sono occupati di
gestione museale sanno bene come una
volta operate le
diciamo le operazioni di base la
raccolta il restauro l'attenzione la
catalogazione rimane questo nodo
insoluto è forse il più difficile da
sciogliere come comunicare il museo ad
un pubblico sempre più eterogeneo sempre
più vasto spesso che entra nel museo
senza neanche sapere bene che cosa va a
vedere
e com'era interno luogo piacevole di
diretto la scommessa sarebbe fare
entrare nel museo pubblici che vanno per
passare una buona
media giornata nel proprio tempo libero
un po con quell approccio
anglosassone in inghilterra ener
veramente i musei sono sempre stati
all'avanguardia per questa attenzione
per i pubblici e che fa sì che si vaga
là dentro con una grande libertà anche
mentale senza
costrizioni di tipo negativo quando il
ministero un tempo ci permetteva di
aggiornarci sulle tematiche inerenti al
lavoro all'interno del museo un ricordo
che in una sessione dedicata alle
diciamo alle disabilità quindi
all'abbattimento delle cosiddette
barriere all'interno dei musei
mi colpì molto la relazione che fu
ottenuta sulla disabilità chiamiamo
psicologica cioè di quel pubblico che si
ferma davanti alla soglia del museo e
non la oltrepassa
ritenendo di non essere in grado da un
punto di vista culturale di comprenderne
appieno la portata alle collezioni ed
ecco allora che credo che sempre di più
questo tipo di atteggiamento vada
combattuto e risolto ed abbattere questa
sorta di ritegno di tipo psicologico e
quindi far frequentare il museo in
maniera libera sia uno dei nostri
compiti fondamentali
chiaramente bisognerà rivoluzionare in
modo di esporre le collezioni l'attenta
diciamo è assolutamente corretta da un
punto di vista scientifico
l'attenta esposizione di tipo filologico
con la correttezza delle epoche storiche
dell'attribuzione ai vari autori è
fondamentale e l'abbiamo quasi per
scontata ma adesso bisogna fare ricorso
al tema emozionale c'è bisogno e che il
museo riesca a coinvolgere questi
pubblici essere estremamente variegati
in una maniera che parli all'individuo
nella sua complessità e non a caso di
recenti
diciamo attenzioni che questo
international council of museum sta
portando per l'evoluzione di un museo un
senso più e innovativo riguarda proprio
la capacità di mettere mettere
l'individuo come centralità del museo e
non tanto gli oggetti che questo museo
espone credetemi non è una scommessa
facile soprattutto per chi come noi ma
mi auguro che le nuove generazioni
invece saranno più come dire propense ad
accogliere questi suggerimenti e questi
stimoli perché come noi era stato
educato ad offrire una visione
ripeto molto corretta da un punto di
vista dell'approfondimento dello studio
e della ricerca
invece bisogna essere capaci a questo
punto di dialogare e di mettersi in
gioco con le nuove tecnologie tecnologie
con la facilità di conoscere che il
nostro mondo attuale ci porta a dover
affrontare e quindi creare degli scenari
che io chiamo emozionali come una sorta
di teatralizzazione del museo che porti
chiunque entra all'interno di questi
luoghi che ritengo siano ancora oggi
sati a viverlo come un'esperienza che
accresce la propria individualità e non
solo dal punto di vista cognitivo ed
intellettuale questo è quanto noi
affidiamo a chi dopo di noi speriamo
saprà raccogliere la sfida
confermando che per chi ci crede e per
chi ha la fortuna di lavorare
all'interno di un luogo museale
credetemi questo è uno dei mestieri più
belli del mondo grazie
[Applauso]
[Musica]